that the studio 54 thing you know that
that blue all I'm saying but then you
know here we go again
cocaine's a hell of a drug Ricky's a
card you know he shows up and my
brother's house nice pie snuggle so
he had dirty cowboy boots let's push
this out of the way barged in the house
my brother had these brand new couches
they were suede right and he gets on the
couch this is why don't I stretch out
and just study crying
mud on another one cause my complexion
needs to call me darkness he calls me
and my brother Duncan tells us darkness
brothers this is long before Wesley
Snipes back then we used to black things
on the planet
twin brother doctors now we stand in
looking at he's with the right in our
eyes it's a grand since mud just did
things just to do them
she's almost live just jump up and grind
my feet or somebody's couch like it's
like this hill so I'm gonna do come on I
got a little more sense than that yeah
I'm gonna drain him up feeling at his
help just did things just to do them
come on she's also just jump up and
grind my penis somebody's couch like
it's like it's you know something to do
come on I had a little more sense than
that
yeah bummer drama then it was like no
way his hands went over there well blaze
hilarious
you were cold as ice
but still Riggs aims he would have to
taking a beating leg day yo couch
nigga this is going out his
legs is like brother you know he's a
he's a lot more compassionate than I am
he's looking at lemon wants Drive wrong
we said why I'm a wit really needs help
house like we just gave him some help
must be answers yeah I bet you he
won't come over here disrespect like
that again wrong wrong
so Rick James cocaine's a hell of a drug